talk about the ones they're likely to be
coming at e3 and the ones that we sort
of the rumors of speculation nobody home
as well so Alexa Mike are you ready to
speculate on the electronic triple yeah
let's get our speculation so here's some
here some read obvious softballs likely
game / maybe that haven't been confirmed
but chances are it's we you enjoy final
fantasy we just talked about a Final
Fantasy 7 remake guess we're gonna see
you maybe I don't know given the track
record with showing that game and just
scores crack crack record track record
showing this game general as I start
about the crack room I don't know you
know I don't know I don't think we'll
get it I don't think we'll get a release
date hmm uh maybe they'll show some
footage but I still think that game is a
very long way off all right um another
one then we're probably going to see I
believe I mean Microsoft's are going to
be coming at this pretty hard they're
one of the few companies still involved
in e3 proper at Gears of War for they've
shown it off already they showed it last
III was when they showed the darkest
gameplay of all time yes thats dark
trailer yeah I ye I can't see anything
like it's your shooting bats like show
with something else and you find a
serious Mike you think they're gonna
plate them all I mean coming out later
this year yeah so they should probably
get on it yeah I'll play it they keep
saying like the main draw with this one
is they're saying they're returning to
like the horror roots the first game
which the first game wasn't really as
like a survival horror no more sentence
I don't know roots of gears yeah you
know they're telling cuz that's also
like the Rob Ferguson was saying that
doing ultimate edition of the first game
was kind of them back tracking a little
bit to those roots could mean like the
scene with a berserker for the first
game and that was I'm scared elements
yeah so but they said they're going all
out with this one and fighting the games
is dark on the dresser smallest train in
the world I was horrifying yeah ways
krill the krill would tear you apart
when you're the dark um I don't know I'm
good curious about that one too I can't
say I'm excited yet I could go either
way yeah I feel like the beta didn't
really light anyone's like expectations
on fire anything no the Bader was fun it
was fun but it was also like mmm like
what
is it like why why am i coming back why
i remember playing this in 2006 yeah so
it's also tough cuz that the first game
kind of raised redefine with third
person shooter could totally so now how
do you replicate that yeah how do you do
that again or improve them and another
game actually of a very instant game
that I'm very excited about guerrilla
games have been working on so many
franchises over the years and I feel
like for the longest time they worked on
franchises that like certain people were
excited about but never got like the
sort of mass hysteria the people yeah
exactly Killzone was a game that like
Sony was pushing a lot I like you know
kids on three looked wonderful in cuz
it's you look wonderful maybe not as
good as it did when they first showed it
off but when horizon zero dawn they're
saying it seems to be like a genuine
sort of excitement bubbling about this
game not just because of how look but
the interesting way in hair plays like
so you excited for horizon very excited
it's different it looks different like
every three people parade out the
trailers and we think oh it's another
gears or it's another thing it's a
whatever but I feel like this trailer
when they showed it last year was the
the first genuine moment of that besides
the fallout announcement was when we
were actually looking at something like
oh this is new this is something
different so yeah I'm totally excited
about it it's gonna be interested is
this the latest game that was the last
game you made shadow fall I think I
think and I think shadow for might have
been the best kill zone and I really
enjoy chatter for I thought it was nah
why do you think like I'll i prefer
three okay decent game I mean I feel
like they figured that series out as
they went to launch here I guess I
wasn't a massive fan of the first game
and yeah so that's horizon zero dawn
coming I guess we'll find out soon
enough look at that look how pretty that
world look I hope it's soon yeah I'm
lawbreakers I mean playing that over
watch video game a lot of people are I
feel like maybe gearboxes one didn't
take off quite as much will know about
that battle born yeah battleborn it's uh
was that gonna Steve forgot it expanding
at the sales it doesn't look like it's
dudes who brought who knows consoles
this will find it soon enough best of
luck to them but this this whole area of
like you know I don't know it's a well
obviously that's more in the MMO space
overwatch is very much as class shooter
lawbreaker seems like it's kind of a mix
between a class shoot around an arena
shooter which is something you know
cliff Kosinski is used to obviously
being part of the creative leads
involved in the Unreal Tournament
franchise you guys
cited almost lawbreakers wanna break the
law break the gravel or gravity shoot
some people Mike yeah yeah so I wasn't
until I read a preview Scott Butterworth
what did when did a preview said he was
pleasantly surprised then it pax east I
got to play it it's really fun it's a
big thing they keep saying is like it's
all about the verbs which most games are
but they say like you know it's it's
very much this kinetic kind of mobility
right it feels more like doomed to me
okay but with with interesting you know
like classes not because do multiple I'm
not a huge fan of yeah despite how much
i love doom but it feels more like that
it's just that it's kind of a floaty
really not twitch based like it's not
like crazy fast time to kill it feels as
like I think we're in like the middle of
the shooter Renaissance this year with
so many gets crazy a bunch of comments
on yeah nobody expected do not be as
good as it was now what that is like the
craziest like exit like most shocking
thing ever yeah like that's happened in
years and first-person shooters made was
the head with deal was on overwatch is
classic yeah like over watches is Team
Fortress 2 and I would say if you're
enjoying overwatch and doom like myself
I was switching between them all weekend
I'd lawbreakers you'll be super into or
if I mean if you're like a old-school
quake fan you like right yeah yeah I'm
really looking forward to this I mean
the other tournament off has really good
but it definitely seems like it's
looking backwards I like the idea of
somebody taking that and looking
forwards in it so guess we'll find it
hopefully we'll find out you're angry we
don't know if this stuff is gonna be
shown recore that's a I mean keiji
inafune you're working on this one as
well Mike number nine is finally coming
out right right there's like between
that and then like the red ash
Kickstarter debacle than the right
sounds like I don't I don't think it's
it's a keiji inafune a game so much as
it is like keiji inafune a is over like
overseeing it or just like producing it
or attached to it in some way finally
good thing i wish i wish all the best
for this game much better than mine a
number nine yeah we'll have to say I
mean yeah that was a game you know that
we saw a bunch of trailers for on looks
no no I mean my number nine was back in
the day and then there was a sort of
expectation and never really mattered
where is record we've seen trailers and
we have seen gameplay and who knows like
maybe maybe it doesn't end up coming at
us as big as big as we want obviously
bigger budget than mighty number nine
yeah we'll have to wait and find out
another game to sort of exists in that
weird world but we have seen gameplay
for his scalebound and Microsoft with a
bang that drum real hard in the first
came out at I feel like was a gamescom
last year's when they showed a big job
but I think yeah I think I was at that
presentation and a deer guys excited
about that I feel like that's more in
your wheelhouse yes certainly than mine
I'm excited about it I'm excited about
it because it's a commie a joint and I
got to like go to the studio last
september's and like talk to them about
skybound and whatnot and their vision
for it sounds really cool like it sounds
like it's like it sounds like the game
is being made by a group of people that
are like these are our childhood dreams
and like this is what we thought it'd be
cool and like they're making it into a
game and that's cool to me because like
we're all kids at heart we play video
games um also it's a dar PG I'm gonna
play it because it's an RPG any came
from Japan so I feel like I have to play
it um but there's some things that I'm
just sort of like well like the the main
character seems a little do right like
Dante yeah it's kind of yeah he's like
cool but in a really not likable way
yeah I took the opposite side of cuz i
was really surprised my sunset overdrive
had a managed to actually hit that one
kind of right yeah he's kind of a dork
and he's committed here like cool for
school was they ran with it they got
like we commit to the dog like worked
this guy is just like derpy is she he's
like a he's not uh yeah I would not call
him up to hang out it's like an
unpopular Sigma Chi in a suit of armor
right yeah perfect my Spurlock's baby
mar said like the dragon combat like ice
like we've seen we've seen we've seen
footage of flying on the Dragon and the
dragon fighting and we haven't seen the
multi mulch of the multiplayer either
right have we seen dragon combat yes I
mean like you fight in the dragon fights
and it doesn't stuff oh yeah i wanna
they talk a lot about the dragon and
stuff the dragon can do and like
different colors for the Dragon yes sir
I don't know they've that's the hottest
thing I want to see more of like the
games sort of story like we know what's
dude and his dragon didn't name it they
made that was a movie pete's dragon how
did dude your dr wayne is dragon how did
how did dude your dragon basically
that's what they should call it how did
you do jack [ __ ] I mean you get over the
last guardian it's called I had an
attitude your dog your talk dragon bird
yeah thing doc bird let's not talk about
that we're probably gonna see it at e3
last guardian you
right I'm just right okay I wonder if
you're gonna see a bunch of nomads
Gainax has been delayed I'm gonna have
to like all right this is coming in
early August you're gonna have to show
us a little bit more I don't know I
considering the way the last week went
with them yeah maybe they won't they
just won't yeah I don't know if they're
coming it's time for it so no but if
like if like power to them for saying we
need more time yeah yeah yeah I mean
that's the biggest game that Syria has
ever made by a mild if like tripled in
size I think I mean it's still not a big
team but they've they've definitely
grown so yeah take your time okay that's
getting to worry weird world of rumors
okay yummers rumors rumors deep silver
gonna add something new that's what
we've with those being floated around at
the moment a lot of people are saying so
we look back at their all games you're
thinking they're saints row which is our
drama but good good vistas Metro series
the dead rising or site that island and
where do we think that might like to see
from them I kind of done with saints row
I loved a sorrow but I'm kind of like I
think it went on I I think it ran its
course I think that out of hell was like
all right yeah that might have been one
step too much almost like four might
have just been enough yeah they got I
was i gay ok just ya party's over go
home yeah um I'd be excited for new
Metro game what about you oh man I was
just gonna say that metro last light is
one of my favorite games um we talked
about earlier when Jimmy was talking
about the 1078 running that on the
10-year trying to run it at full
capacity on the 1080 so it can't be done
no an eye on one card I think metro last
light maybe it's just my instinct that
to fill out a trilogy they need a new
game but if they did I would not be
because to tues if you haven't played
last light that ending is just one of my
favorite things when I shooter ever but
um I would be super excited if they
announced a new one I think like those
are something like there are traces like
half-life in those games yeah and how
the yeah tell the story and how you're
playing that game in the pacing I really
hope that's what it is let's talk about
some of the big guns Rockstar Games
Grand Theft Auto 5 I mean they're gonna
be launching GTA online stuff for that
for yawns I wonder if we're going to see
any single payer DIC I kind of feel like
we won't because it doesn't really make
that much money in comparison to what
they're doing with the online stuff yeah
but can you see anything else from am I
mean the big one is like red dead
redemption right like
everyone wants a new Red Dead game yeah
it might be that I think it's too early
for GTA 6 mmm I would like to see story
dlc for GTA 5 if you like the longevity
of gtn line in the game itself I feel
like I feel like if they wanted to
commit themselves to single-player
narrative DLC for that game they could
they be fine cuz people liked it I mean
GTA for the bottle of gay tony was
fantastic the yes like the biker one was
called Lost and Damned was really good
too yeah yeah well red dead as well
you've been like it is it time like this
is their problem at is that they have
this suite of franchises the ones that
worked in the ones that didn't work that
the warrior sitting over here they got
bully you is kind of like somewhere in
the middle and then they've got the sort
of big guns do you think they have to go
for another red dead or do you think you
know maybe they'll show off something
else and again this being rock star who
generally tend not to enhance big things
at e3 either yeah that's sort of that's
what sort of makes me a little hesitant
about it like maybe it's not one of
those big things maybe it's something
different um I thought it might be agent
but i'm pretty sure agent is dead yeah
yeah i mean GTA 5 they basically just
ideal we're gonna put this trailer up at
this time everyone come and watch it
like they're big enough where they can
do that so i guess have to find out
another big one of course being taught
Herod's team they have packed 404 is
done and dusted the dlc for that game
i'm sure is being handled by a smaller
team whenever they seem to be done they
roll them out onto a new big project and
when they finished up Skyrim they all
started work on fallout 4 10 4 is near
done are we going back to the other
schools I yeah that's my wild card for
the show is right Elder Scrolls six the
abyss I'd see it's kind of soon to
announce an elder scrolls obviously
based on their the pattern but yeah i
don't know i wouldnt be surprised they
did i'd be surprised but pleasantly
surprised and the bethesda we have now
is a different bethesda to what we had
like five years ago where they could
just rest on one game every couple of
years i mean they have these press
conferences now and granted they've also
like expanded and they have it software
and they've been working with other
teams around the world you know when
they had gives like Wolfenstein of stuff
that's underneath their approach you but
that's being made by totally different
team in europe's not even part of made
so like they do have a lot of stuff
going on but you feel like Bethesda if
they are going to do another one of
these big events they really needs I
mean they can't just have like elder
scrolls online stuff they need they need
stuff yeah
yeah so yeah cuz it's just what
dishonored to right now yeah maybe
there's some doom stuff I don't know as
far as like new games right yeah yeah um
tango GameWorks hasn't announced what
they're working on okay could you evil
within successor whatever right yeah
yeah but again you took that's on that
sort of BCT right and like yeah name so
yeah hopefully that'll be amazing I mean
last year they stole the show so I bet
they'd probably like to do it all over
again let's talk about some of these
Japanese games got down here like so all
of this I can always count on you for
this and near automata new near game I
love near it was weird and stupid and
amazing and I'm so happy they're doing
all that this game is actually being
made by platinum oh right Platinum's
making year here automata there was a
not a press conference but Walt light
was all he was unconscious there was a
like some new gameplay trailers went out
and it looked really cool it looks like
a really good real-time action game
excellent so I'd like to see more of
that Kingdom arts three just how it
works yeah that's my wildcard it's the
thing I hope to see um Final Fantasy 7
remake I'd love to see something persona
5 they came out in japan in September
dodge of course so if it's coming out
this year then like I think Atlas would
be kind of silly not to show it in some
capacity at e3 I hopefully thought it
was your label hopefully it's not too
loud because it's beside our booth on
the show floor herbicide herb yes so I
had to listen to like that persona 5 for
dance personally I'm a lean over and
over again you got to see the teddy they
did have a Teddy dancing in there so
whenever I'm interviewing people in the
background it was Teddy just like doing
his thing amazing he was pretty good
that's what those are my hopes my hopes
and my dreams not as far east but a
little bit about depending on where you
are I guess and is our good friends in
warsaw city project red cyberpunk 2077
obviously something that they have been
you know there's a lot of you know
fandom behind all they've ever shown as
I won't trailer which is pretty cool
with that bullet song great job all that
hype also though there was an earnings
call or like an investor thing they had
back in March would they talked about a
brand new game a new project which was
something that they said like isn't
going to be like any of the other
franchises they've worked on before so I
don't know what the hell that thing is
where there's gonna be a smaller thing
at a bigger thing and maybe they'll show
that thing off as well yeah whatever
that is I'm so they get different genre
or they sounded like it yeah you can
they did a presentation
chevensky did back in and I talked to
him I tried to talk to him about it
during GDC and he was having none of it
tape yeah same here right my interview
him about blood and wine but yeah I
wasn't talking about like cyberbunker
they're so good they are so good at
being just like definitely mom totally I
mean even with the witcher 3 like they
were so they have the sort of PR release
things so good they've gotta sit down
and they've delivered which with the
witcher 3 said I think that's why people
are even more excited about cyberpunk
than they were before um but yeah so we
don't know what that thing is we don't
know what genre is I got the impression
it was a different genre I got the
impression it wasn't like a spin-off of
any other other games it was like a
brand new thing I mean who knows I mean
they might make it bloody I was about to
say collectible card game but they
already made Gwen yeah maybe that oh no
you said it's not a spin-off side be
amazing if they did like went mobile or
like a net right like went game what it
though how much laying off Gwen how much
money would they make though that was
like instant money bloody baron that
goddamn green card that'd be great they
said you know we'll we'll see but you
know cyberpunk not coming out this year
they've said as well so maybe we want we
want to I would have to see anything
else you guys are thinking about I mean
we haven't talked about the hardware yes
the PlayStation 4.5 neo stuff seems to
be pretty set on I mean there's been so
many random sources that have come out
about it at this stage right yeah um I
think I think that I mean then all the
xbox one there's next box yeah xbox lamb
there's the new one maybe next year
there's now all this chat about virtual
reality coming out of Microsoft which
there wasn't preference but no separate
to that it seems like yeah yeah huh Pete
Brown him being the expert a lot of
these things he was saying Microsoft
could kind of like steal the show if
they show off the stream box like that I
crackdown 3 reportedly use but also like
I think they would need to be careful
about not using the word cloud because
that every time someone says I just kind
of stuck yeah fading away but they said
then there the crackdown 3 like physics
momentum oscillator trailer yeah yeah
that would they send that was all cloud
stuff so that's why that you could
destroy everything yeah but you said the
separate box nope so Pete was saying
like there were there were rumors about
a stream box yeah right so like I don't
know I just for like playing games oh
like it sighs dream again I don't know
on live I don't know I don't have to her
like that so you could I don't know I
wish he was here cuz he could describe a
way better than me you can nightly
concession could
use that cloud data it's actually like
negate the memory you need on your xbox
it no compliments that or something
right so like I don't know if they did
something like that that would be pretty
that might be the thing that sets them
apart from Sony because I feel like Sony
got out ahead of the game with their 4.5
stuff and that seems like a like an
obvious increment for one of the
questions here from Avengers for the win
as very savings as my question is why
would they release an xbox slim when
they're just going to release a new Xbox
next year because that's what we're
hearing is that and who knows right this
may be the same rumor that's getting
split up somewhere along the line in
like a crazy game of telephone but
apparently they're saying that we're
going to have some sort of slim version
this year and then and then the new one
next year like if that's the case the
messaging around this is obviously two
weeks from now we'll know exactly what
it is yes I mean that does seem like
they'd be doing a disservice to the you
know skoo they're going to release this
year right itself but it's also the same
as like the the whole PlayStation 4.5
thing the 4.5 neo whatever we're calling
it is is is graphics like that's why
it's being released its being released
for graphics and maybes improved memory
and nothing else like it's not going to
have the sony or rumors are saying that
like sony has I think Austin Walker's
awesome piece said that Sony has already
told developers that they cannot make
exclusives for either one right yes be
the same like one has to have they have
to have a mode for normal and regular
for every game that comes out and it's
like ah like I don't know like I feel
like it's too early feel like it's too
early so I'm in 4016 I didn't until
uncharted and doom Cambridge and then I
was like oh no we're good like both
these games like doom runs at 60 and
looks amazing a bit of texture pop on
the console version as there is actually
on the pc version but like it's fine
i'll try to for it looks amazing yeah
and you wouldn't want to play that game
in 60 I kind of like it that sounds
crazy and another jump all over me for
it but like I love that game the way it
is exactly I think it's perfect it's
always I'm always curious how much that
the competition is pushing certain these
companies i mean i'm sure it happens all
the time but i'm wondering how much that
the song catching wind of the sony news
cause microsoft to say [ __ ] we should
just make the Xbox smaller something to
try to compete until next year yeah you
might be right I mean I microsoft is
leagues and leagues and leagues behind
Saudi yeah at this point so they need to
do they need to come out on par with
them they need to be on par and come
at the same time and be in lockstep with
Sony or they're never ever ever going to
catch up yeah i mean the biggest robin
they had forever was that they were
basically playing catch-up from the
metric era as well ever since they you
know the new sort of leads came in here
so then X and then it leaving a next
unit cell thing who knows maybe even
1000 fully complete like you know whoop
on our son is like you hired an exit to
watch it's a watch Jamie Game and Watch
we're back it could be this we can watch
wasn't watch but whatever could be what
could be one now Oh two weeks two weeks
little less than two weeks oh yeah by
this time we'll we'll know so much all
right